[Music]  if you had a secret and you knew that it  would ruin somebody's life would you  keep it a secret  would you come clean why would you want  to ruin someone's life  [Music]  how was your journey with cam Walter was  it fulfilling I don't really know how to  clear the phone this is wonderful you  had sex with your daughter's girlfriends  and you're feeling guilty yes I feel  guilty actually a lot cooler having you  here than I thought it would be P has  lost too soon did you think this was  gonna go in to be one big happy family  gonna go to Hawaii and snorkel your  daughter is the only good thing that I  have going for me to live without  regrets  sometimes regrets are our blessings look  around you this is all for you  [Music]  whatever you do take a lot of pictures  you